Welcome back, we are here with Chelsea Clinton.
All right, so I found a picture, Chelsea, and it just,
it really, it did everything in my heart.
I love this picture so much.
Look at how lovely, where is this?
Okay, so this is in the Governor's Mansion,
'cause my dad was Governor.
I really wanted to be a clown
and I really wanted my mom to be a clown.
And my mom just said, okay.
And so one of the reasons this is also so special
is this is the last time we dressed up together.
Yeah.
Well, maybe-
I love my mom.
This Halloween, maybe it's time for twinning 2022.
Twinning 2022, yes.
(audience claps)
I'm in, I'm in.
All right, so this is one of our favorites.
This is one of your favorites.
And can I ask you-
I think, I hope, great, yes.
About some favorites in your life?
Of course.
Okay, are you ready?
Let's do this.
(audience claps)
I'm like, am I ready?
All right, I'm ready.
I feel like I also need to shake it out.
What's a favorite present that your parents got you?
Ooh, probably the train set that I got.
Cute.
Yeah, I loved my train set.
Yeah, I think my train set that they gave me for Christmas
when I was probably about that age, like five or six.
So you were like, they get me.
Yes.
Did they ever get you a present where you were like,
they don't get me?
Not really.
But I will say my paternal grandmother,
my grandma Ginger, who passed away when I was 13
and is one of the great,
I don't know, if you can really regret
things you can't change,
and yet it feels like this great regret for me
that I didn't know her as an adult.
She loved everything bright,
everything bright.
Like she wore bright colors, she wore bright makeup.
Everything in her house was bright
except for the life size cutout she had of Elvis
in black and white in the corner.
This is my point!
Everything was bright and amazing.
When I was growing up everything was Elvis.
Everything was bright, and then there was Elvis.
And I have always had more
muted tones in my life.
And so every year, my grandma Ginger would give me
the brightest colored sweater or skirt or like hair bows.
And although, at the time, I was like,
oh, she doesn't get me.
I now get what she was trying to do.
Trying to bring brightness and color.
She was trying to bring brightness into my life
and I wish that she would've lived long enough
so I could have said, I understand.
(audience claps)
Maybe you can say it.
Yeah.
Okay, favorite midnight snack?
Oh god, it's so boring.
I really liked almonds and dark chocolate.
Isn't that boring?
I needed something more exciting, but it's the truth.
(audience laughs)
Eh, the truth is what I want.
I'm sorry, okay, I'll try to be more exciting
for the next one and also truthful.
Okay, your favorite thing
that your husband does around the house?
Sings with our kids.
Aww.
It is really cute.
We, like I'm sure many of you who have small children,
we watch "Encanto" every week now,
and we listen to the soundtrack every night.
And my husband is such a good sport.
And so all of our kids are singing whatever
in their own registry of like, "We Don't Talk About Bruno"
and Mark's like right there with them.
Okay, your favorite TV show right now?
Well, I love "The Great British Bake Off"
more than maybe any television show I've ever seen.
People love it.
I real really do love it.
And my kids also like baking shows.
So we watch "Baking Impossible" which was fun,
where there was like a baker and an engineer.
We just finished watching "School of Chocolate."
Okay, favorite movie right now?
I mean, I haven't seen any movies
except for with my children.
I mean...
the other day I was like,
we have to take a break from "Encanto."
I know we all love "Encanto."
And so then we watched "Moana" again.
And I was so happy to see "Moana",
whereas like last year, I was like,
oh my gosh, I need a break from "Moana"
and then we were watching like "Frozen."
Have you seen "Sing 2"?
We loved "Sing 2."
And the soundtrack is great.
The soundtrack is great.
I highly recommend it.
"Sing 2" though, got quickly displaced admittedly
by "Encanto" in our house.
Okay, throw on "Sing 2."
Yeah.
Okay, your favorite thing to do by yourself?
Nobody's watching,
and yet.
No, I do, I run and I don't let anyone run with me,
which is maybe not the most generous place to be,
but my husband, I'm like, I'd love you, no.
Or even my friends-
I love it.
Who are big runners, I'm like, that's great,
you can go right and I'll go left.
It is my time, it's my time.
(upbeat bright music)